this satellite image shows a field
outside the Eastern Ukrainian town of
volada littered with destroyed tanks and
infantry Vehicles Ukrainian and Western
officials say this is the result of a
battle which has already cost Russia
dozens of military vehicles and hundreds
of troops since February
the coal mining town in Ukraine became a
new focus of Russia's offensive due to a
strategic location from here Ukrainian
forces can Target Rail lines linking
Russian occupied dinesk to the Crimean
Peninsula a major base for moscow's
operations The Wall Street Journal
analyzed videos taken within two miles
of volada and we spoke to British and
American Military experts to find out
what this offensive reveals about the
state of Russia's Army a year into the
war
in late February Ukraine's Army shared
this video of an intersection just
outside volada
Kiev says he shows a Russian armored
vehicle running over a land mine
the area where at least seven other
vehicles appear to have been damaged
looks like what military experts call a
choke point as the video shows Russian
troops drove down on narrow route to the
intersection making them easy targets
for mines in Ukrainian fire
despite the obvious dangers Russian
tanks seem to roll onto the same trap
again
and again as we see in another video
released a week later Ukrainian soldiers
on the front line say Russian forces
kept making similar moves
um
military experts who watch these videos
say this shows that Russian troops
received orders from the top and most
likely didn't have the autonomy to
adjust to the situation on the ground
and that is an extreme example of how
Russia's military didn't adapt from the
old command and control system from the
Soviet era another issue the analysts
pointed out is that it appears the area
wasn't cleared of mines before the tanks
moved forward soldiers would normally
use smoke to cover themselves from enemy
shelves but videos show it didn't happen
here
military analysts say one reason it
could be the poor training of recently
mobilized Russian soldiers
Russia's Army has paid a high price for
the decisions in volada Ukraine said it
destroyed at least 30 tanks and infantry
fighting vehicles within 10 days in
February
whole Russian Brigade was effectively
annihilated or destroyed they lost
nearly a thousand or over a thousand
people in two days Russia's defense
ministry didn't respond to the journal's
questions on the losses in volada but
its spokespeople have repeatedly claimed
successes against kiev's forces in parts
of Southeastern Ukraine exercise
some experts believe Russia's Hasty
offensive in volada could be due to the
kremlin's desire to show results of the
months without major victories
Western officials say the Russian army
has been played by chronic issues such
as an ineffective command structure and
poor training since the start of the war
and the setbacks in volada suggest the
issues haven't been resolved on the
battlefield one military expert said
willardas shows a high price the Kremlin
is willing to pay Russia hopes to
overcome Ukraine's resistance with more
soldiers and military hardware before
Western weapons arrive to help the
ukrainians